ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
مرحبا بك معنا على شاشه العربيه شكرا
اختيارك العربيه للظهور عليها الجيش اعلن
انكم تلقيتم عدد من الاتصالات من عدد من
رؤساء الدول فيما يتعلق باجلاء رعاياها من
السودان ما الذي دار بينك وبينهم وتم
التنسيق والترتيب عليه سياده الفريق
مرحبا وعليكم السلام طبعا
قالت هذه الدول قلقونا من مالات الاحداث
الجاريه الان في السودان وايضا نحن
نشاطرهم هذا القلق لان الاوضاع الانسانيه
والاوضاع المعيشيه والصحيه كلها في تدهور
يومي مستمر والجميع يحس كما ايضا نحن نحس
على ضروره ايقاف هذه الحرب وهم طلبوا
تسجيل
اخلاء رعاياهم
ووعدناهم بالقيام بالامارات الضروريه
لتامين وخروج رعاياهم وخروج امن ما هي هذه
الاجراءات التي ستقومون بها سياده الفريق
كيف ستضمنون سلامه اجلام مواطني ورعايا
هذه الدول من السودان
نحن نخسر المطارات اللازمه ونفصل الممرات
الامنه في بعض المناطق التي
بها بعض الاشكالات الامنيه هل كل المطارات
تحت سيطره الجيش
كل المطارات تحته الجيش مطار الخرطوم في
اشكاليه ومقار نياله في اشكاليه بقيه
بطارات السودان كلها تحت سيطره الدوله
وبالتالي مطار الخرطوم لن يتم من اجلاء
مواطني اي دول او رعايه بسبب حده
الاشتباكات حول المطار سياده الفريق
طيب يعني هناك من ينظر بان مساله اجراء
اجلاء الرعايه من السودان هي تنذر
بالتصعيد كبير سيكون خلال الايام القادمه
هل هذا حقيقي
من الممارسات مجموعات الدعم السريعه داخل
السكنيه فهي تفتش المنازل وتصادر الاموال
وتعتدي الدبلوماسيه دون اي مراعه لحرمه
هذه البعثات ولقوانين التي تعمل بها حتى
دون اي مراعاه لحرمه المواطنين
الان هذه المجموعات منتشره داخل احياء
سكنيه داخل المجمعات الخدميه وتقوم
بافعال ادخلت الخوف
الوطنيين
قبل يعني سياده الفريق هذا الانتشار لهذه
القوات قوات الدعم السريع في الاحياء
السكنيه في الخرطوم يعني بانكم لم تسيطروا
بشكل كامل على العاصمه الخرطوم حتى الان
نعم هنالك وجود لمجموعات كثيره جدا من هذه
القوات وسط الاحياء السكنيه لتفادي ضربات
المدفعيه وانتخابات ضربات الطيران نحن لا
نريد ان نقدم على هذه الخطوات حتى لا نحصل
ضرر وسط السكان او وسط المجمعات السكنيه
ونحن نطالب
حتى اذا كانت هنالك فعلا
معروفه للحرب يجب ان لا تتم لا يتم
استخدام المواطنين كدروع البشريه يجب ان
نجد هذا السلوك ادانا من من الجميع هل تم
فعلا استخدام المدنيين دروع بشريه في
المواجهات بينكم وبين قوات الدعم السريع
بالتاكيد الان مجموعات كبيره اخرجت
المواطنين في المنازل اخرجت اخلط
المستشفيات واحتلت المستشفيات موجوده في
كثير من الان قواتهم داخل الخرطوم في
مناطق سكنيه وسط السكان والصلاحيات
السكنيه الفريق يعني هناك نزوح كبير
للمدنيين من العاصمه
الخرطوم يعني السؤال عن من يسيطر على
المفاصل المهمه في العاصمه اليوم هناك
تضارب للانباء بانكم سيطرتم مثلا على محيط
قياده القوات العامه المسلحه على المطار
على عدد من المناطق الحيويه داخل
الخرطوم حقيقه السيطره اليوم في العاصمه
الخرطوم كيف يمكن ان تتحدث عنها
احنا كنا موجودين في مقراتنا وتم الهجوم
علينا من قبل هذه المجموعات المتمرده طبعا
نحن نقوم بالدفاع ولا نريد ان نخرج نخرج
الى خارج دائره الدفاع لاننا نظن ان ذلك
يتسبب في اضرار كبيره واضرار بالغه على
السودانيين الان الاف الاسر تشردت مئات
قتلوا
البنيه التحتيه يتضررت في حرب عبسيه ليست
لديها جدوى سوى اكاذيب التي يدعيها الطرف
الاخر لانه يحارب الشلول ويحارب الجماعات
الاسلاميه الان
ما في واصابه مقدرات الدوله واصاب القوات
النظاميه
الدوله السودانيه في
اجتماعي في قوميتها في وحدتها لذلك هذه
الادعات الكاذبه التي صار بان الحرب ضد
الجماعات الاسلاميه هذه اكذوبه يراد بها
استعطاف بعض المجموعات التي تنافس هؤلاء
الجماعات العداء نحن نؤكد ان الجيش هو جيش
سوداني خالص وليس جيش للبرهان ودليل انه
برهان في كل الولايات في السودان هنالك
سيطره للقوات المسلحه على كل الولايات او
على كل الاقاليم هذا يدلل عن القوات
المسلحه قوات قوميه قوات معركتها هي ضد
الهيمنه التي يدعى اليها بعض الاشخاص او
بعض المجموعات التي تريد ان تستحمل على
الدوله السودانيه طيب فيما يخصكم سياده
الفريق يعني هناك انبات حدثت بانكم يعني
خرجتم من العاصمه الخرطوم بسبب يعني
الاشتباكات القريبه من محيط القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه القوات الدعم
السريعه نشرت عدد من الفيديوهات قالت
بانها اقتحمت مقر
اقامتك شخصيا هل تستطيع الرد عليها او اين
كنت اصلا منذ بدايه هذه الاشتباكات وحتى
اليوم
انا موجود في هيئه قياده القوات المسلحه
ومضارحه ولن ابارحها هذه هي مهنتي وهذا
شرفي لن اخرج الا محمولا على نعش لكن انا
موجود واقوم بواجبي دستوري وادافع عن
الدوله السودانيه ولا ادافع عن شخص ولا
ادافع عن جهه
[موسيقى]
ولا دافع عن بقاء مدافع عن السودانيين
جميعا انا موجود صحيح المنزل تم تسلل نصوص
اظن ذلك نصوص المنزل من بعض المنزل
هو ليس داخل القياده بالمعنى ان كنت تسلل
لبعض النصوص وعاصم فيه فتانا
السؤال المهم اليوم سياده الفريق الى اي
مدى زمني ممكن ان تستمر هذه الحرب هل
لديكم يعني موعد محدد او لديكم استراتيجيه
عسكريه تبنون من خلالها وقتا زمنيا او
توقعا لنهايه هذه الحرب
طبعا
اي جهه تبدا الحرب بالتاكيد تعلم الى اي
مدى ستنتهي هذه الحرب وكيف وايم هذه
بديات معروفه في الحروب ما في جهه تعرف ان
الحرب
طبيعه السودان طبيعه السودانيين ط
العمليات الجاريه داخل المدن تحتاج الى
جهود كبيره تحتاج الى صبح تحتاج الى طول
نفس كلنا نعلم ان الحرب داخل المناطق
المبنيه ليست
مكشوفه او مناطق اخرى
الزمنيه هنا غير وارد الناس متاكد من ان
الله بعد اسبوع بعد 10 يوم لكن نحن نناشد
بان يجب ان تتوقف هذه الحرب يجب ان نخرج
كل المسلحين من داخل الاحياء السكنيه يجب
ان ناخذ كل المسلحين من المنشات القدميه
الان الاقسام الشرطيه محتله المستشفيات
محتله المرافق الحيويه كلها
محتله لا احد يستطيع ان يقدم خدمه
للمواطنين السجون تم اقتحامه واطلق صلاح
كل المجرمين هنالك جزر فوضى شامله قد تعم
السوداني اذا لم ننتبه جيدا ونوقف جميعا
هذه الحرب اللعينه الفوضى الشامله ما الذي
تقصد يعني بهذه الكلمه هناك مجموعه
الازمات الدوليه كانت قد حذرت من ان
السودان قد ينزلق الى حرب اهليه بسبب هذه
الاشتباكات وبسبب ما يحدث اليوم في
السودان هل تعتقدون بان هذا سيناريو مرجح
سياده الفريق
بالامس اقتحمت مجموعه من الدعم السريع
سيدنا الهدى وهو اكبر سجن في العاصمه به
رابطه 8000 وثم قتل الحراس والضباط واطلاق
شرح جميع هؤلاء السجناء اتيهم المجرمين
فيهم المخدرات يوم القتله اليوم ايضا
سيدنا نزار به الاف برضه من السجينات الان
ايضا اقتحمته هذه القوات
جهه تقوم بمثل هذه الاعمال وتستحق اقسام
الشرطه
معنى ذلك ان هذه تريد ان تشير الفوضى في
الدوله طيب اسالك عن قائد الدعم السريع
مباشره محمد حمدانو اعتبر انك غدرت به
وصفك ايضا حتى باوصاف اخرى منها انك
انقلبت على السودان وبانه يجب ايضا كذلك
تسليمك للعداله كيف تعلق على كل ما وصفك
به سياده الفريق
انا اقول رمتني
كيف اكثر من ذلك
طيب اتهم ايضا حتى فلول النظام السابق
بانهم يحيطون بك بانهم هما هما
لمهاجمه قوات الدعم السريع
وهو يعلم تماما انني ليست لدي اي علاقه
بالنظام السابق ولا جميع يعلم ذلك نحن
قوات مسلحه نعمل احترافيه وواجبنا حمايه
السودان حتى
معظم هذه الاشاعه يعلم المصداقيه ويعلم
انه انها كلمه حق اريد بها باطل او كلمه
باطل اريد فيها ما هو مصير دقله بالنسبه
لكم في الجيش سياده الفريق
كما هم يفعلون ذلك هم الان يستهدفون
القيادات للقوات المسلحه ويرسلون اتياما
القناصه لتقتلهم نحن لدينا نظم
ونحترم العادات والتقاليده العسكريه كيف
سيكون القتال لا نستهدف شخصيات لا نستهدف
اشخاص نحن نستهدف مهددات الامن الوطني
نستهدف العمل الذي يغدر بامن الدوله هل
تعلمون الان اين هو حميتي او لديكم
معلومات سياده الفريق
اتهمتم عدد من الدول الاقليميه بانها
تساند الدعم السريع تساند مباشره محمد
حمدانو هل يمكن ان تكشف لنا عن هذه الجهات
سياده الفريق
معلومات وردت بانه هنالك محاولات هذه
المعلومات في مثل هذه الظروف تكون متواتره
من جهات مختلفه لها مصلحه
وكان هنالك
حديثه حتى متصل به شخصيا هو واكد بان هذه
المزاعم مداعم يراد بها الفتنه والوقيعه
بين الجيران
هناك معلومات اجنبيه سربت عبر الصحافه يوم
امس وايضا حتى خلال
الايام الماضيه منذ بدايه الاشتباكات بان
الدعم السريع الدعم السريع عفوا تلقى دعم
باسلحه من قوات فاجنر ما هي دقه هذه
المعلومات اولا بالنسبه لكم سياده الفريق
نحن نتحرر من دقه هذه المعلومات حتى الان
هل انتم يعني
مستعدون
للتراجع عن دعم
عن دمج الدعم السريع مع الجيش كحل للازمه
سياسيه الفريق هل هذا مطروح على الطاوله
ابدا هذا هو المطلب الذي دعا دعم السريع
الى مواجهه القوات المسلحه نحن نعلم ان
الدوله بها جيشين فيكون مصيره مصير لا
يحدث الان لذلك يصير ان الدمج يجب ان يكون
جزء من الاتفاق الذي توافقنا عليه جميعا
هناك اي خلاف بينكم وبين الروس سيد عبد
الفتاح العلاقه كيف يمكن وصفها يعني بعد
الاتهامات
تساند قوات الدعم السريع اليوم في السودان
تقاتل او ايضا حتى تمدها باسلحه
معظم الدول لدينا علاقات مميزه وجيده مع
روسيا مع امريكا مع كل الفاعلين في
المجتمع الدولي يحتفظ بعلاقات متوازنه
معهم بالنسبه للدول الحدوديه معكم
هل هناك اي خشيه من ان تنزلق في هذا
الصراع من ان ايضا تتدخل في السودان
اتحدثون عن اثيوبيا اتحدث عن تشاد ايضا
كذلك
علاقتنا مميزه مع اثيوبيا وانا على تواصل
مع الرئيس الاثيوبي ونتشاور في كل امر هم
البلدين الاخوه في تشاد ايضا لدينا معهم
تواصل يوميا مستمر وهما اغلقوا الحدود
والان يمكن المئات القاريين من الدعم
السريع تم تحافظ عليهم في الحدود مع مع
تشاد
وايضا مئات السيارات
ايضا تم التحفظ عليها موافقه القوات
المشتركه مع تشاد يعني انتم الان تنفون كل
الانباء التي تحدثت على ان هناك انباء
على ان هناك توترات على الحدود بينكم وبين
تشاد مثلا
ابدا نحن نعمل معاشات في تنسيق جيد ومستمر
ويوميا نتبادل المعلومات ونتبادل التواصل
مع الرئيس محمد دبي هم الان على الحدود
موجودين
ويتحفظون على كل شرط حار هارب من من الدعم
السريع يحاول الدخول الى تشاد الولايات
المتحده هددت بوضعك شخصيا وحميه ايضا على
قائمه العقوبات ان استمرت هذه الحرب كيف
تعلقون سيره الفريق
انا ناقشه في سبيل الدفاع عن بلدي وفي
سبيله في اي عقوبات تصدر من اي جهه انا
اقوم بواجبي ومستعد لتحمل اي مسؤوليه تنتج
عن ادائي لمهمتي ولواجدي
فيما يخص الهدى سياده الفريق اكثر من خمس
او ست هدى اعلنت في السودان منذ بدايه هذه
الازمه لم يلتزم اي طرف بهذه الهدن الهدن
وتم اختراقها من تحملون المسؤوليه هل انتم
جزء من هذه
هل انتم جزء من مساله اختراق الهدن
الانسانيه في السودان
اي هدمه اعلنت اصلا ما فيه حتى ابتدعت لان
القوات الطرف الاخر غير مسيطر عليها وهي
منتشره في مناطق مختلفه من الاحياء
السكنيه وكل يعمل بمفرده كثير من المحال
التجاريه تم الايداع عليها البنوك
المؤسسات الدوله هؤلاء الاشخاص
حتى البنوك لذلك هنالك في كل حركه
يستخدمون الاسلحه يستخدمون القوه تضطر
القوات المسلحه لان ترد عليه هل انتم
جاهزون لاي هدى انسانيه ترعاها الامم
المتحده او دول ايضا اقليميه
بالتاكيد نحن دوما نزعه الى عدم التصعيد
ندعي الى حقل دماغنا الوطن نزع الى
المحافظه على مكتسبات الدوله السودانيه
نزل على المحافظه على نسيج الاجتماعي
والوحده الوطنيه كل اجراء يساعد على هذه
الامور نحن سنضفيه ليس لدينا مصلحه يعني
يموت او يموت السودانيين او تدمر البنيه
التحتيه للدوله بالنسبه للعمليه السياسيه
سياده الفريق في السودان ما هو مصيرها
الان
نحن ملتزمين
بالصراع لان هذا الصراع هو في الاساس جزء
منه صراع سياسي نحن نريد ان ننهي هذه
المساله ونحن مقتنعين بان الحكم العسكري
ليس لديه مستقبل في تطوير اي دوله في
العالم لذلك حريصين وان تكون في حكومه
مدنيه اتتولى الشان عقوبه مدنيه متوازنه
ليس صراعات لا تجر البلد الى صراع جديد
يعني في ظل كل المطالبات بالتهدئه
الوساطات الدوليه ايضا والاممي التي اعلنت
خلال الفترات الماضيه الدعوات اليكم انتم
شخصيا والى قوات الدعم السريع هل يمكن ان
يعود الوضع بينكم وبين قوات الدعم السريع
الى ما كان عليه قبل هذه الحرب
طبعا لا يمكن ان يعود الى مكان عليه قبل
هذه الحرب لظروفا الحاليه التي نعيشها
الان
طيب طالما انتم كلكم
كقيادات
داخل القياده العامه الا تخشون من
الاستهداف
[موسيقى]
اذا كان قتلنا في سبيل ونحن مقتنعين بان
ما واجبنا ولنذهب
اخيرا ما هي رسالتك الى
شقيقه ايضا
انا
اقول ليس بها كاسب
مثل الاكبر هو الدوله السودانيه لذلك يجب
ان تتوقف هذه الحرب يجب ان يعود المقاتلين
الى اماكنهم يجب ان نجلس جميعا سودانيين
ونجد المخرج الملائم حتى نعيد الامل ونعيد
الحياه الى من ينظرون الينا الان
بدراسه وبحزنه وبشفقه
رسالتكم ايضا كذلك الى الشعب السوداني
سياده الفريق
[موسيقى]
مع انه كما ذكرت لك في البدايه انك كل ما
نبدا الحرب لا اعلم نهائيه ولا اعلم مهما
كانت توقعاته وما كانت حساباته لذلك
السودان مليء
بالوطنين
بالمخلصين مليبي من يتحدث بصوت العقل ونحن
نرجو ان تدخل العقال والوسطاء الذين تخدم
مصلحه البلاد لمن انزلاق البلاد الى
الفوضى الشامله اشكرك جزيل الشكر انضم
الينا عبر الهاتف رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
شكرا جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات